hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the samsung galaxy s7 active uh and
i'm really happy and a little bit
disappointed with this phone at the same
time i'll explain so you already know
the galaxy s7 right you've seen the
review you know it's a great phone and
it's one of the best samsung makes right
now so the galaxy s7 active is all of
that plus the following differences one
obviously the much more rugged exterior
so this is meant to be an active phone
like the galaxy s6 active from last year
so it needs to be able to take more
drops stand up to more harsh conditions
and just generally be more durable as an
everyday device and the rubberized
backing and the frame help it do just
that giving it a military-grade 810g
shock resistance and also maintaining
the ip68 dust and water resistance from
the normal galaxy s7 i showed this as
someone actually the other day and their
first reaction was wait what case is
that and it's kind of funny it kind of
looks like a thinner phone wearing a
case but that's essentially what it is
it's a rubber rim that hangs around the
front a little bit to protect the screen
when it's face down and it beefs up the
corners where most impacts happen if you
were to drop it so it's basically like
having a really good case on the phone
at all times it's not the prettiest
thing in the world but it's definitely
functional now samsung is also saying
the display is shatterproof not sure if
i buy all that i mean it is still
gorilla glass 4 but it should be a bit
harder to shatter or crack from a normal
drop especially with the rubberized
corners but it is what it is a really
tough phone you will still have physical
navigation buttons as well at the bottom
like last year's active surrounding the
new home button which does have a
fingerprint sensor this time the
physical buttons are definitely easier
to press when you're doing you know
active stuff and this phone also has a
custom key up here at the top left that
is completely programmable for up to
three different actions now a single
click a double click and a long press so
that's pretty dope and you can dive into
the settings and make this button do
essentially whatever you want but i
think it makes sense to have it launch
your favorite apps from wherever you are
on the phone even when it's sleeping to
top it all off now you've probably
already noticed this phone is a little
bit thicker than normal samsung gave the
s7 active a 4 000 milliamp hour battery
4
000 million powers and they're not even
bragging about it that's the thing i
know some phones that are like pretty
bad but a lot of people buy them anyway
because their main selling point is two
days of battery life and people just
need battery this phone has 400 milliamp
hour larger cell than the galaxy s7 edge
that already lasts me all day and got
great marks for the battery in its
review so all other things held a
constant this is looking like it's going
to be a power sipping endurance champion
and then everything else about this
phone is what we already know and love
about the galaxy s7 so you know best
display in any smartphone the quiet hd
5.1 inch super amoled it's back
one of the best if not the best cameras
in any smartphone also the 12 megapixel
sensor with f 1.7 glass and optical
image stabilization that's back
the top-notch specs plenty of ram
android 6.0 marshmallow
the speaker's still not that good and
it's still skinned android so you
probably already know if you like the
software experience or not since it's
the same as the galaxy s7 but now it's
just built like a tank and not everyone
can do pretty and dainty the all glass
galaxy s7 is honestly one of the most
fragile phones out there because of that
material so this is a big contrast to
that so honestly the biggest problem
with this phone and the reason why i
said i was a little disappointed with it
in the first place
is that it's an att exclusive it's only
on just one carrier in the us only now
samsung this is a flagship like this is
better in a lot of ways than your
current flagship the best phone you make
in the galaxy s7 so this could be the
best phone you make right now but now a
lot of people will never find that out
because it's limited to just one carrier
in one region and it gets all you know a
little bit of bloatware from att and the
branding on the back but if this phone
were unlocked or even on multiple
carriers or even more than just a t it
would actually be a big player for me to
be recommending to people or even over
the galaxy s7 so instead it's being tied
down by att and that's kind of a shame
hey maybe next year samsung so what do
you guys think would you buy the galaxy
s7 active even over the regular s7 for
its features let me know and that's been
it i'll talk to you guys the next one
thanks for watching peace